on n'a pas pu la combine
c'est super tu es de quoi je parle pas
tiens
voyez vous le cul quand même parce que
je retiens à venir enfin quoi et
d'appareils pécule un coup de main je me
suis fait mal et je n'arrive pas
pendant ce temps là il pense pas un
instant qui fait ça
france pas mal il marque par la déprime
c'est le drame
et vous qui pensez à mal alors ya ce qui
fait le gros y'a tout est tombé à l'eau
voici une
une fois je suis protestant monsieur
lambert ça peut [ __ ]
vous avez quoi dans le paquet est lassé
des chocolats oui bonjour manger en bout
un moment donné j'ai un petit coup
devant moi je venais de l'hypoglycémie
monsieur moi oui mais l'adolescent placé
pour un enfant et à la poule
je resterai gosse mois donnez moi votre
tour viendra pas question d'oublier des
drh et de la haute savoie c'est pour un
enfant la mesquinerie des gentils je te
tiens tu me fais la queue - cp t2
devrait pas changer la roue dit malgré
qu juste pour moon est arrivé
des millions dans ma poche la visite
pourtant sont allés sinon pourquoi t'as
des couilles dans le sondage allez-y ça
me démange n'hésites pas d'aidé moi
c'est le docteur ma poche je prenais à
l'éthique bombe raté juste un peu des
couilles dans le fonds allait discuter
des éléments pions et ça démange depuis
ce matin non mais écoutez vous êtes fous
si mal c'est pas bien à soulager voici à
l'avenir de m finalement je préfère
l'autre c'est-à-dire l'hôtel a plus de
gueule loyer celle là c'est pas un mot
nieuws et remettez d'autres promettaient
celle là celle là l'est alors laissez
les jeux pas l'armée mais c'est pas joli
à regarder c'est pas la même couleur
regarder pour accuser en fout.ce pour le
centre ou pas j'ai pas roulé qu'une
caisse des blaireaux si c'est pas joli à
l'hôtel relais avec a rappelé faisant
cependant voiture est la mienne elle est
là bas d'autres voies
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous émettez un
pouce bleus